all right
oh god
big shout out today to helix sleep take
their two-minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to the mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life find
your perfect mattress at helixsleep.com
griffin
thank you to our sponsor five cbd they
make full spectrum cbd and thc products
that you can feel
it ships legally to all 50 states so you
can send it to a friend go to
5cbd.com griffin and enter code griffin
at checkout for 30 off and free shipping
on your first order
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen
welcome to your
absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
all right as you know
haven't done this in a while and we're
back and we never know what this guy's
gonna do but welcome to the podcast
mr
rick glassman yo thursday on the
afternoon the party's sick and often do
but now we're stopping dipping and
taking it in the afternoon but if you
push and pop it and keep it until the
better noon and you would do it and do
it into the blood moon now we just
pushing it aside like you're rocking in
the
you take it you give it up and give it
then you love it then you shake it then
you click click
oh start over i want to do it again
[Music]
all right and we did it i was not in the
mood to do it and when uh
i was thinking like is there a chance
he's not going to give it to me because
you're like we haven't done this in a
while and then he gave it to me and i'm
like i can't say no yeah you got to take
them like
headphones on what are you doing
what do you guys think
it's not live we could have done it live
but not i was i was ready to do that
maybe when i got here four hours ago
oh you're one to talk like you're always
ready when i get to your place so when i
came up here and you weren't ready like
there were some you were friends it was
probably 15 minutes in the chair of
doing stuff that i that i get yeah but i
got here two hours ago yeah but we
wanted to talk about the wedding stuff
and then i was also doing my podcast
earlier i think you could have done it
earlier no but i mean you knew i was
coming yeah you always you know when i'm
coming too i got no problem actually i
didn't know you were coming you know
that's crazy because i usually hear from
you so you didn't necessarily confirm
and you still came so i was like oh
yeah but
like day of i've i've had this
experience with you in the past where
like she messaged me a few days a year i
know but usually on the day of you kind
of get like hey am i still coming like
you're usually like that so but i did
message you day off when i said i
because originally i'm supposed to get
here at once no no i know i know when
you sent that message keep this in i
know when you stable like okay no when
you said that message i was like oh he's
still coming i'm saying usually the
night before you can't even say you know
that you know your hands are still
coming tomorrow i could appreciate that
i think i think what happens there is
it's not like we made these plans two
weeks ago we made these plans like three
days ago still i know so so you know so
i don't need to follow up a day later
you do though that's your way i could
come back no no it's fine we cleaned up
you know did you
break the camera
[Laughter]
you actually told me this is us cleaned
up yeah yeah yeah yeah hey it is what it
is we're we're
you know what though you can't have
you can't have
a super clean person
and a super messy person living together
that's not gonna work
it's gotta be
maybe a super clean person with a messy
person that is
pliable or it's too messy so what you're
saying is if you're super messy you have
to be with another super messy or
someone who's okay with being messy
anybody who's okay with being messy is
super messy well i mean no one's like i
no one's just super messy no no i
disagree because there are people who
are like neat freaks
and as opposed to
someone who's like clean but like they
don't mind if
you know the dishes aren't done yet but
that's dishes aren't done yet isn't
super messy super messy is the dishes
just go in the second sink
you know that's that's their final place
no no no okay i understand what you mean
there's levels right you know it's like
autistic levels of like you know
messiness but super messy
with a clean person i guess also
like if the super messy person also like
does a lot of stuff
is the bread winner yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then it's like the other
person's like well i got to clean up
after him but i clean up after him or
her
in a beautiful home
but yeah i couldn't i no i still think
it doesn't matter i still think that
there's a mentality
i think there's a thing about a person
who is like
like a neat freak or someone who's like
you know i'm just saying that you're
talking super messy neat freak most
people are not either of those i know
but that's why i'm saying those two
couldn't go together but i'm saying and
even like what i'm saying is that gap
between the two so let's say this is the
middle when you have it like this i
think the thing has to be like that or
like this so you're saying there's like
close together but i think they have to
be like like it has to be like that or
like this with the middle being there so
if the mic is the middle it can't
necessarily be like this it's got to be
like that okay on to the next subject
what
why would you like at this point i'm
just like all right
yes or no but what you don't understand
is listen it can't be here it's gotta be
like this
even you're you're already checking your
phone no no because i wanna so i need to
check my phone cause i wanna pull up
i wanna pull up your text messages
because i wanna why are people always
reading my text messages all the time
yeah because you know why because you
this is what you do you like change the
narrative and the story later okay but
the proof i'm so comfortable with that
not being the case
okay go ahead
you know what
we don't need to if you don't watch
because you just read that you're like
oh no no no no no
it's so far back i don't even know how i
don't even know what you're referencing
what i'm referencing is what i talked
about on the podcast before so now
you're here to defend yourself what i'm
saying is this i'm going to go through
the the process oh the american idol yes
yes i'm going to
yeah american idol
because we could i want to talk about it
because it's now done and we could talk
about american idol but before we talk
about that i want to say that and also
even though it's done for us
if you
audience
haven't finished the new season of
american idol heads up
we're going to talk about it that's all
i need all right okay let let me talk
first and then you can go all right i'll
pull them up it's sunday okay it's
sunday american idol has already come on
rick is now hitting me up
monday night
midnight really late okay also no no
let me just say one thing
if you watch american idol on hulu
it doesn't come out until monday who
knows you're watching it on hulu who's
watching it on cable i have youtube tv
and i record it
who's watching it on youtube tv a lot of
people like the nba finals is being
promoted by youtube tv okay
now i have to pull it up to make sure
you're not uh leaving anything out okay
because you
don't
cause because
when you scroll up it doesn't have to
wait for it i know it's so annoying
all right here we oh i found that i
found it what's the date um
okay may
may 9th okay 11 24 p.m okay hold on hold
on everyone may 9th
11 24 p.m right which is monday which is
the next day or as i like to call it the
day it came out for me okay fine but
check this out even the day came out for
you this is what you say
greatest season of american idol ever
that's the first text let me talk and
then you can come in okay
i'm going to talk first
may 9th didn't you already talk first on
your podcast shut up okay may 9th 11 24
p.m
the day you say it again it came up
rick day came out rick may 9th even if
it was the day it came out yeah may 9th
11 24 p.m the first text
greatest season of american idol ever
question mark
i am loving loving is in big caps these
fritz is so great
stop full stop that's it i say back
man
christian was robbed
okay
rick writes back wait and then i've
already started typing that dude is
great then he goes say nothing dude uh
that's what he says and i go what
okay and he's like i'm still watching
yesterday's man
okay
okay
yeah oh i love that look on your face
because you know i'm right
okay yeah here's my point rick i don't
know from your text message you don't
know anyone would think you've already
watched it you could say what you don't
know oh here we go go on go on explain
it wait let me just ask you this
am i out of pocket to assume that all
right already watched it uh yeah
yeah uh you're not out of pocket to
think that maybe i have okay this is
great because there wait wait let me
just it's my turn not yet not yet not
yet not yet because i'm presenting my
evidence oh okay i'm predicting evidence
okay rick
the show has already come on even if
you're watching it on hulu it's already
come on
you're sending me this message because
we know we both love american idol
and i must i'm taking the assumption
here that okay he's watched it that's
why he's messaging me wait wait wait you
said watched past tense right yeah okay
great now how do we know it's past tense
because of the because of the suffix ed
not watching watched rick because the
show's already come on
you assumed i watched i don't i am
watching no i assume you watched it
already because of
you the nature of your text messages
could we please just start corey please
greatest
greatest season of american idol ever so
i all i'm saying is
it is
crazy for me to think no no it's not
crazy that you've already watched it
that's why you're messaging me yeah okay
okay so what i'm saying is okay if you
were in the like to me part of this
first few text messages should be
man i'm watching this right now
and this is the greatest season ever
because then i would have said oh man
let me know when you're finished may i
now floor is yours so the first time you
bring this up you said am i out of
pocket
for assuming yeah and then you changed
your turn for saying assuming to
thinking because when you assume it
makes an ass out of oh whatever it is
whatever whatever all right
and you're an [ __ ] and you know who's
also an [ __ ] people that say that
i didn't say it the way it said it i was
being ironic deconstructed people are
actually do that
greatest season of american idol ever
question mark you know why i said
question mark rick excuse me
may i have
go ahead
go ahead
greatest season of american idol ever
is it i don't know yet i haven't
finished it
yeah but do you know that from this
go on
go ahead go on he knows he's wrong go on
i'm listening so me and blake griffin
are listening
man i loved this episode
no oh i didn't say that i didn't put it
in past tense it does it
okay so you're trying to tell me you
think that there you think of this i am
loving i am loving these yeah these do
you not know what these mean
these nuts i don't know oh so you don't
know what it means then why assume that
i finished i am loving these you you say
greatest in america i'm thinking you're
talking about what the episodes what do
you think these can mean the episodes
yes
not the current episodes all of the
episodes yes okay does that include the
current episode so
is the current episode
part of what i'm loving
probably right i didn't say i loved
these
i said i am
currently because this is loving and the
season and the season is still going on
so but you said it's not done but you
didn't think these meant seasons you
thought these meant episodes of course i
can't say i love the finale which by the
way spoiler alert was the worst episode
of all of them oh don't we can talk
about that after we get through our
thing i wasn't saying i'm loving those i
didn't say i i i didn't say man i love
these can't wait for them all i'm saying
is eric you got i'm gonna leave no we're
gonna let you no i'm saying rick rick
rick you're trying to say i get this i
am loving these but you follow it up
with fritz is so great yes i'm watch i'm
watching let's say i'm watching a game
i'm watching a game and a player is
doing great i don't know that he's going
to be spoiler alert they're going to
lose okay rick how about this oh i'm
glad you brought that up this is perfect
okay can i get it like if you said like
let's say we're watching the playoffs
right and you recorded it i don't know
and then you go like this i'm loving
these playoffs steph curry mostly
no no no
curry is going off and then i go damn i
can't believe they lost and you're like
oh you didn't finish the game yet oh you
already you know what you already
stepped in it
you can't make fun of it
as i said steph curry went off
that would be different than is going
also correct me if i'm wrong most people
watch the nba finals live
most people
watch american idol
after the fact no they don't that's why
they do live voting and 20 million
people call in 20 million vote people
are 20 million votes because each person
could vote 10 times per person that's
its own [ __ ] seven million people
voted seven million people five whoever
rick rick right right five million wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
right right five million people you know
how many people would vote if they had a
whole week look at what look what
happened before said nobody watches it
live nobody watches it live you said
whatever you said relative to the nba
finals if you look at the nba finals not
true because they're not getting great
ratings i'll put money on i'm saying no
no i'm not saying finals to american
idol what i'm saying is
out of a out of all the people that
watch the finals okay we'll call that x
and all the people that watch american
idol will call that y
the percentage of x that watches live
versus not live is more live the
percentage of y
isn't as high as x okay check this out
all right perfect perfect
i love that you said hey
so
in your example
the nba finals is over
that's my turn it's my turn it's my turn
no no no the game is my turn i'm not
listening i'm not listening i'm not
listening i'm not listening no no no no
no no no you're not gonna let me not get
my point
i'm gonna get my point
the game not the finals because american
i don't know wait american idol wasn't
over check it out check it out game six
is over all right check it out we're
talking about game six let me talk
there's two episodes left game five game
five whatever concede
for game five
i love you're trying to not because you
know i got you right here i'm trying let
me finish
it's now game five right
game five is over
it's the next day
and you say to me i'm loving the finals
i'm loving these finals yeah and i go
and then you follow it with
stefan curry is great then i say
can't believe they lost that game and
then you go i haven't finished watching
wait wait listen listen listen this is
your example you brought up
am i
is it terrible of me to think you've
already watched it no that's what
happened
and i'm saying the finals is the mic no
but the finals is different than
american idol and also don't use the bid
the finals is the example
you said your x and y and most people
watch it already so i was using i'm
saying x the finals
most people watch it live so to assume
that they didn't if i'm talking about
the finals it's two days later it's the
day it came out american eye for you
for
most people no you're watching it on
hulu most people watch it
on regular tv you know what we neither
one of us have the data for that okay
but i will say this
if i'm watching a finals game
and i'm messaging somebody about the
finals game
which is much more immediate
already happening to me than american
idol which is once a week and people
don't watch any show they don't watch it
the day it comes out they have their
week okay finals multiple games per week
i'm just going off what you said rick i
was saying it's different than the final
okay okay but using your example i'm
right
okay what's my example your example of
like x y this this amount of people
watching wait wait it seems like you
don't understand the example cause you
just don't understand explain the
example the example is this rick if
people aren't what yeah exactly explain
explain my example all i'm saying is no
no no explain my example that you're
trying to put against me yeah because
you're saying that most people watch
sports live i'm saying more people who
watch this sports game okay watch it
live i get it who watch a tv show so
later so what i'm saying is if we're
talking about the finals later it's okay
for me to assume that you've already
watched it
even because it's live even though and
let's say you didn't watch it live you
just happened to have recorded it and
you're watching it right now what i'm
saying is this it's not wrong of me to
assume
that you already watched it it's wrong
to assume
anything with spoilers
it's less weird for sports if it were
the finals game and i'm a day behind on
the finals game i would say to you
hey man i haven't finished the game and
what i would say to you american idol
you don't need to do that yes you do i
disagree i don't think can we agree to
disagree on that point we are that's
such a stupid saying because we already
are disagreeing you're just trying to
say we can move forward
that's what i'm saying what i'm saying
is on a television show
spoilers
to assume that somebody watched a show
when it comes out on streaming which
let's at least say
a lot of people okay watch it streaming
you gotta give at least a week no no no
no no check it out check it out i
disagree with you
not when you receive loving not loved
those messages like that also and i'll
put that it's going to be on the screen
right now the messages are right here
boom okay also snap it this wasn't a
huge deal to me
this wasn't uh i can't i understand how
that could happen yeah i listen i
wouldn't have done it oh but i
understand what could happen what i'm
what what what got heated wasn't the
fact that you assumed i watched it i'm
just like man in fact my ugh my ugg
didn't even have an exclamation point oh
it was full caps no it wasn't let's go
back and look go ahead let's go back and
look i'll stay right here not looking
i'll just look at your face you tell me
if there's caps okay
yeah all right the first but it was
capital a capital u yeah cause there's a
period before it well then you should
know that you shouldn't put a period and
then do the uh no i'm still watching
period
that you're out of your mind
cause that's a rig voice text what got
me what got me heated i actually said i
actually said uh i actually said i'm
still watching period ugg period
what got me heated wasn't that you
spoiled it which you did which happens
i wanted to tell you that to condition
us so you know hey man next time
just say did you finish it what got me
upstairs oh oh and i'm saying to you hey
man next time open with oh i'm still
watching oh oh i learned my lesson oh
you're good did you learn what you're
going to be upset with something that
you do all the time oh here we go which
is this
hey man you [ __ ] [ __ ] you should i'm
like eric what you spoiled where's that
where's that no it's the energy oh how
do you know the energy because i'm
saying it's something that you do all
the time this is who you are i'm not
even talking about american idol what
about this is who you are okay
it was you dude
and you are mister
i can't say that
i can say that okay we're done we're
done hold on this has been rick glassman
well thank you for watching hold on
you spoiled something i didn't spoil it
see and here's where my issue is i'm not
saying that when he does that when he
goes in here i'm not saying you did
something intentionally i'm not saying
you did something that is unfathomable
what i'm saying is you're walking down
you walk you're walking in air one all
right oh here's another
this is going to be a ridiculous example
but go on air one is a grocery store
that is known for their thin aisles
that's what i'm getting at all right
you're walking in this you know what
they do have some thin ass um
you're walking in right and you're
you're you know what you haven't been
there in a while and you're looking for
stuff then you found it there and you're
excited and you get the bags and you're
doing this and you've got oh look at all
these 15 bags of dried mangoes and then
you turn
small aisles man you didn't see me you
bumped into me
not a big deal
but you know what you do
you say
my bad no no no no i know no that's not
that's you go like this
this [ __ ] no no no no that's not
true at all it's acknowledged no no you
spoiled it for me how about you
acknowledge that this series of text
messages i understand it could happen no
no no no see but you didn't get spoiled
and this is what you do you didn't get
spoiled what you do is you never own
[ __ ]
own that you
that this is also your fault
own it
own it i got it
i got it
you know what you're looking at what
you're looking at whose fault it is no
you're an only child oh right that makes
sense because you would get in trouble
and there's nobody to blame it on i get
it now this is what you do you had
nobody to blame this is what you do
um you know what this would be the first
time i've seen it i'm sorry i'm sorry
that you grew up that way oh my god
i know i can appreciate i can appreciate
it oh my god you see this this is what
my issue is
you think you didn't do anything wrong
i think that if i could go back why are
you yelling oh cass letting the [ __ ] out
of this are you yelling hey you're right
let me calm down yeah calm down rick why
are you yelling i think see when you
grow up with brothers and you have to
fight all the time you get you're so
aggressive that's what happens sometimes
sometimes
thanks man yeah good
so you're looking at it as false no i'm
not oh oh i misunderstood when you said
own that it's your fault too i
misunderstood so you're not talking
about owning your part of it my what i
don't like is you're sitting here acting
like
i'm the only person that did anything
wrong i don't think the spoiling was
that big of a deal
that's not what i'm saying listen when
you foul somebody in a game of
basketball there's a dif i don't think
it was a flagrant foul i understand but
you hit the shooter it's part of the
game it happens
is it my fault for jumping i didn't hit
the shooter they hit the shooter this
went to the nba office and they're still
looking at it right
now i don't know listen man that guy he
flopped you're a flopper check this out
you're a flopper my question for you my
question for you is this and see if you
can answer this and be [ __ ]
non-biased as much as you can just this
what am i buying
[Applause]
without without like i'm trumping you
admittingly admittingly without context
my question i'm asking admittingly
without all the other contexts or as
you'd like to say 95 times
nuance yeah okay it's very new without
the context and nuance answer we have
the nuance i'm saying i'm saying just so
we could build we're gonna build we're
gonna start here okay because we're
calling a foul here how many minutes are
we in on this go ahead
and we haven't even gotten to the
spoilers yet but people fast forward
they're going to get to it now
i fast forward 45 minutes we didn't even
have it
answer me this question not whose fault
was it wrong could rick have done
something different could eric have done
something different
just answer me this one literal
objective question
was the episode
spoiled for me yeah
okay and why was it spoiled for me no
we're gonna listen
the why wasn't an issue for me
and and that's what i'm saying just to
not acknowledge just own that part of
you just say oh my bad
how about of course i could have said
how are you gonna say how about you say
oh my bad i should have told you i was
still watching
because we didn't
because we didn't even get to
not the issue of the spoiling rick we
went right to
[ __ ] you okay so how about you how about
you give me an object now we're doing
the whole objective thing now why don't
we do what we could have both done
differently
don't write no no you're not going to
get away no you said you all calmly like
hey objectively so let me ask you a
question then yep like
it's it can you see how if you start the
conversation with i didn't text you it'd
be one thing if i texted you like bro
american idol is i can't believe
christian was robbed if i hit you first
then that's like man i'm i'm i
i don't
i already know because i don't watch it
live either so i already know you don't
no play the tapes back i don't watch you
live youtube live that's what you watch
i said to you you said people don't
watch it live most people don't watch it
live percentages compared to finals i'll
say people do watch it live because
that's how they get the live of course
people watch live it's a live show
nobody watches your podcast live all i'm
saying is but some people but some
people do yeah rick all i'm saying is
you started it off with this greatest
season of america and i don't ever
question mark i am loving these
fritz is so great
could you
i
already seen i understand how that could
happen okay that's that's it but that's
it but but honestly that's it but i
wouldn't have assumed he watched it i
just i would ask did you finish
oh my god okay
but okay when i said hey man not not
anything about here let me get exactly
what it was
what
when i said to you
that i didn't say anything about you
[ __ ] up
i said man chris you said christian get
robbed i said wait because because for
before we even deal with what needs to
be healed let's stop the trauma let's
just before we deal with you know all
the fluids that need to go in let's put
pressure on the wound for a second wait
wait wait wait
so then you said say nothing dude uh you
said what and then you said that dude is
great so now you now i'm just saying
hold on hold on before we even go
anywhere i say say nothing dude oh
because you're still typing to say
nothing just hold on for a second just
now i know now you go what because at
the moment i'm realizing this idiot
started texting me about american idol
and have it finished instead of thinking
about what i'm going through you're
judging my intellect
i'm just saying i'm not judging
right well idiot not meaning like it's
not like you called me a [ __ ] right
yeah yeah i did because it means the
same thing to me idiot [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] so all i'm not saying i
didn't say this eric no this one you
know what you go ahead because i'm going
to ask you respectively for 30 seconds
so go ahead okay you go you go i'm still
watching yesterday's man with a quest
with an exclamation point and that's
when i get mad [ __ ]
so defensive
talk about idol and not be caught up all
right and then you go come on rookie
move you're so defensive and so wrong
that's what pissed me the defense oh no
you were pissed off beforehand you're
calling me a [ __ ]
but
like i it's like [ __ ] you gotta watch
but my man wasn't man my man was this
man how do i know and how do i know but
i never yelled at any obscenities to you
or called you wrong no what we need to
do is like when this happens we need to
get on facebook what we need to do is we
need to have two people who know no
context or us read these out and hear
their context and how the so
actually
it's actually a super funny way to do it
i think i think like this they go like
this actually and both actors go
actually he should have and you're like
no matter [ __ ] this you wouldn't even
you wouldn't even take it then
so
so hear me out i've heard you out no no
you i just i'm gonna hear you up let me
just say this one day i'm gonna say this
one thing you have yet to even take any
ownership of anything how many if i were
editing this i would cut all the time
and said you're right i absolutely could
have said it differently i could have
made it more clear i see how that could
have happened okay we're done that's it
that's all i need
i said that numerous times no you didn't
eric let me get into this episode
numerous times that'd be great you want
to edit
comment this is how i'm you know what
this is like me i'm tom i'm uh i'm
huckleberry fitting you i'm making you
pay defense
yeah okay that's how i do it well i'm mr
miyagi and you and i'm making you do
this so many times so next time you'll
be like did you wash it you're not him
no did you like the pun at least
wash to watch did you wash it did you
watch it did you what about mr miyagi 2
or you know where's take the coat off
you know sorry listen
to this listen to this okay can we just
move on i got it i got to get this out i
got to get this out because
because you're
you're seeing this through your reality
which i uh i could see
i see a reality and i see yours you're
but no you not seeing
your issue is i spoiled american idol
for you and and i got mad at you
my issue is not that you spoiled
american idol huh
what is it
hear me oh jesus look at me look at me
tell me my eyes are look at you
you're not sincere i'm sincere that you
that's your sincere if that's your
sincere you're gonna have a lot of
troubles
okay i have autism and i've learned
facial expressions don't even [ __ ]
use that the the facial expression i
haven't learned i don't know but people
are really people being sincere they do
do this they go
they put their lips together they also
go like this they also try and slow
things down with their hands and go
okay so that's what you're doing okay
here's this my issue
is not then i was upset that it was that
it was um spoiled for me not eric
griffin spoiled it just me watching the
show it wasn't even about you she's like
ah [ __ ] man right the issue comes from
i'm still i'm looking okay uh christian
was robbed wait dude that's great say
nothing ugh what i'm still watching
yesterday's man
i just wanted to say don't say anything
and you went right to
[ __ ]
you should have you should have instead
of saying i didn't point blame at
anything well i did that's what i'm
saying i know okay so the fact that i'm
just like ah [ __ ] i stubbed my toe you
know here's how if you could remove
yourself from it it wouldn't have
happened if i stubbed my toe instead of
me like uh you should have been wearing
shoes which i should have i know you
would have been like oh that sucks you
know i know the issue right now the
issue is this make-believe version of
rick glassman that you think you are in
this scenario but i know rick
that's not how you did it
you are this guy how you're acting with
me right now is how i pictured you
texting me
oh you were creating a story right oh
see here we go
no i i just this is what we do i'm
talking about my pre-existing
relationship with rick glassman how we
go at each other about the most minute
but you don't listen
up
how many times did i have to say i could
have said it different how many times
did i have to say i understand how you
could see it that way
all i'm saying is just say my bad and
then i could the conversation then could
have been about yeah whatever
it wasn't about spoiling it was about
you throwing the blame on me when i
wasn't even talking about blame i'm
talking about american idol man
we'll be right back
marshall's roy gallery
are you sick and tired of all the same
merchandise from all of the oh let's buy
this sweatshirt let's buy this beer cozy
at rick glassman.com or at tyso cards
you could pick up these custom
businesses all getting cut out really
oh that's right girl you go go go do
your cards we get
rick rick glassman and goblin
blake griffin mark maron is iron man and
the newest eric griffin
let's do this because you don't have
[ __ ] you don't zoom in capabilities
what are you talking about zoom in kate
now you're going to mess up the whole
thing now the whole thing's going to be
it might be now you just ruined the
whole thing
my bad yeah
my bad
i didn't realize it was on auto focus
but you can't get mad at me for assuming
oh shut up exactly that's such an
annoying thing to say no you're annoying
okay off man and everybody agrees with
me yeah they do yeah i'll give you that
yeah let me just wait hold on a second i
just want to make sure i wonder if i
have
i don't know if they told me ahead of
time let me just can i just look at my
ad calendar and see what it is we are
this would be
may what is it right now it's oh it's
about to be june wow
june
what's the date today it's may 30th
so next week would be
the sixth
so we'll come out on the seventh
which would be
oh man that's a helix sleep
actually before we get into can i tell
you something yeah i sleep on a helix
mattress yes
it's a great mattress it's a fantastic
mattress actually no but i don't even
want to make it seem like it's a sales
pitch i want to tell you because because
because you know you do these things you
try them and sometimes they're okay
sometimes you don't want to advertise it
and sometimes they're great and
obviously you could go to their website
you could take the two minutes leave
quiz which by the way you've taken it
right i have to maybe it takes a minute
i think they say two minutes just if
that
are you a do you like a firm mattress do
you like a i'm a i'm a side sleeper i'm
a back sleeper oh do you run hot or cold
i run cold i run hot
so
you know what such differences that we
could agree to disagree on but i will
say this one thing we can agree on helix
mattress is a fantastic mattress
absolutely fabulous now tell me correct
me if i'm wrong you get to try it for 20
days right and then they i think it's a
hundred days actually wait a minute it's
a hundred days a hundred days and but
then you have to pay to ship it back if
you don't like it no they'll actually
pick it up for free wait a minute you
have to go pick it up but if they don't
like it they'll pick it up for free you
don't even have to pick it up rick they
send it to you so they'll send you the
mattress send it to you try it for 100
days try for a hundred days you don't
love it yeah right you send it back that
and then what you but you have to
probably pay for the shipping back
the whole thing's free so make sure you
go to helix sleep.com
tyso griff for up to 200 off all night
and you get a free pillow
griffin
that's helixsleep.com
for up to two hundred dollars of all
mattress orders and two free pillows
we'll be right back oh and check out
tysocarts.com
griffin
what's up guys let's talk about five cbd
which i have tried yes
i have tried it and it is great five cbd
was founded by hemp enthusiasts to
unlock the power of full spectrum cbd so
you can unwind from the grind
since the products have regulated
amounts of thc you can get a nice buzz
while keeping a clear head and they ship
legally to all 50 states five cbd for
everyone
life moves fast and sometimes you gotta
chill i'm telling you guys
i'm not usually
this person but i tried it and i loved
it
super mellow man
i uh when i did it i'm just it's so
chill and then i go right to sleep and i
wake up and i feel great i like i got a
really good night's sleep so i do highly
recommend it if you're not someone that
wants to get high and you don't like
that feeling because i'm like that i
don't like that feeling i don't want to
be high i don't want to be drunk i don't
be anything like that so i was a little
nervous at this but i took this and it's
it's like
perfect it's
perfect right there where you want to be
if you want to be super chill so in
essence you can think of 5cbd as an
extra strength
relaxation tool really and i love it
um their industrial hemp is grown in
america and u.s hemp authority certified
five cbd products are third party tested
no gmo
and grain free
riffing with griffin listeners get
thirty percent off and free shipping on
their first order of five cbd
go to five cbd dot com slash griffin and
enter code griffin at checkout for
thirty percent off and free shipping on
your first order that's five
cbd.com slash griffin and enter code
griffin at checkout for 30 off and free
shipping on your first order
anyways so we saw american idol you saw
the final i hated it i fast forwarded
the final i wouldn't say i saw you know
what i'm saying can i tell you something
when when christian got taken out and
when fritz was out i was done yeah and
and then and then by the way i as soon
as first of all i called the finals i
knew it was going to be hunter girl i
knew she was going to be in it but i
thought it was going to be hunter girl
christian
and fritz as a final three and then i
knew i wasn't surprised that he won by
the way oh as soon as i saw him in i was
like oh that guy's going to win
i knew he was going to win because
that's who wins american idol straight
white males that play guitar
they want americans to say it's less
about qatar and more about country oh
that's but that's even that's even uh a
cherry on top the cherry on top is the
country but by the way
no shade on the guy at all no no no
there's none at all that guy's great
he's he's really good okay you don't get
to the top ten if you're not yeah yeah
yeah he's really good and this thing
about i'm not and by the way it's not a
racial thing this is just a fact of like
who's one american idol like i don't
even care who's gonna be and eric
griffin says only white people win
american idol well i mean so it is a
racial thing no but i'm just saying this
um how about this it's never the best
singer well this show and even the
judges will tell us it's not a singing
competition oh no but they do say that
it's a singing competition they say that
they say that it's an it's it's looking
for america's idol not best singer
they've said that during the audition
rounds well they've changed that because
of probably because of the results
because in the past they've said many
times that this is a singing competition
it is a singing character
people they can't sing go out well in
the end it turns out that that's but i'm
saying this though if you're in the top
five you're already you're already
potentially a great idol that's why
you're there
you would think right they they lost me
after they burned they they blew their
load on disney week that was the best
not just because the performances happen
have been great but like i want to hear
the disney songs yeah i don't need to
hear and also no shade to carry
underwood congrats on everything you do
i don't need a carry underwear theme oh
bro you know what a cara android theme
is for one bar mitzvah
yeah you could i couldn't
i dug my keys into the side of this oh
that's carried over
and also i wouldn't have known jesus
thank them
oh that's her song yeah she's not bad i
i'm not no shade but i'm just i wouldn't
have known but have you ever heard of
this song
can you feel the love
yeah because that's awesome i do i
totally agree with you and by the way
too hey american idol contestants
sing the disney songs we know
okay i knew most of them stopped picking
the b-sides from the
from the crap disney movie no but you
you're talking about like moana and
stuff yeah dude
those aren't our disney generations
maybe i really think that's what it is
no but sometimes i still feel they don't
even pick the lead track it's like you
might be right this is like oh this is
like this other track that i'm gonna
fool people with no no man
when christians are saying circle of
life i watched it so many
that's like big boy from last year i i
rewatched that too that dude was great
he should have won but i also understand
because you want to talk about singing
and you want to have that idol thing
hidden hat at but so i get it but now
the term idol is changing to like
involve all body types oh exactly so we
live in a world right now where you go
why then are these other people losing
country i think is a big part of
american idol a lot of the winners are
country and a lot many of the finalists
i don't know if i would say many of them
we should actually look that up i want
to look that up and see but i just know
this
white guys that play the guitar win
american idol a lot okay shout out to
white guys who play the game yeah versus
versus really great singers let's move
on from american idol because i don't i
don't have stakes in this game anymore
right we're done with american idol
let's talk about as we see it i'm hoping
that's going to get a second season i
don't know
i don't know but i will say that amazon
even though they didn't pick it up for a
second season yet which means it might
not go they're pushing the hell out of
it for awards and it should it's you
know what it's an important show i
thought it was it was like really great
show i think anybody that watches that
show will be touched by the subject
matter and the performances rachel's mom
loves you
okay like rachel's mom wants to sit next
to you at the wedding because she loved
that show so much you know anyways they
the sh the show meant a lot to everyone
i mean rachel she was crying i mean you
know what you saw i sent you the video
so anyways it's a great show i do hope
it gets the second season if it doesn't
i'm going to be furious and i'm going to
be talking about it um straight up
because it's like
with with the world we live in right now
with like inclusion and all this kind of
stuff and there are many people out
there who are who are i don't want to
i'm not even going to use the word
suffering with this because it's not
suffering but i don't know you may even
say that
living trying to live their experiences
one of the benefits so people say
there's there's so much great tv which
there is they also say there's too many
shows that's subjective yeah but the
truth is there are a lot of things and
what streaming has offered is because
there's so many shows being made there's
a lot of stories that are allowed to be
told of niche categories that if there's
only 10 shows this probably wouldn't
make the cut right right right if it was
just nbc and they got it and they only
have
per night so with this idea of all these
stories being told and these new
opportunities of lead characters uh that
represent these stories and these
lifestyles
now people are getting to see themselves
and uh doing a lot of press and meeting
a lot of people with this show
not even including so many messages that
i've gotten which one of the coolest
ones
yeah one of the coolest ones is how many
people have messaged saying not only did
they not know much about autism since
the show they have since been diagnosed
and they found out all of these things
oh that's that's what this is they
relate so much to this how important is
that and i'm meeting these people both
on the spectrum or directly connected to
a lot of parents with kids with autism
thanking me
and when i say thanking me uh i'm able
to receive it the way it is though they
are thanking me they're thinking me as a
vehicle because i'm there what this is
is i'm just an actor on the show it
could have been somebody else this story
is being told that i am part of it's not
like i did something but no i'm stopping
you i'm stopping you i'm stopping you no
rick it's not true
you did it it is you
you did a great job and
they hired you
what i liked about what they did was
they didn't just hire an actor to play
someone who's autistic which i have no
problem with that's why it's called
acting okay
i've talked about that in practice get
me started
when they talk about how important
representation is i say it is important
to give opportunity and to tell the
story authentically but i do not believe
that everybody should only be playing
the things that they are yeah because i
think that is ridiculous yeah it'd be
funny if like that's the reason they
like they say they don't pick it up and
they pick it up because you don't know
how difficult it is to make this show
you want to know the truth what if it's
like
they
they are autistic
[Laughter]
would have to be like oh man you know
the show
everybody who is part of that show
behind the camera and in front of it
is so
patient and kind and loving and loved
and i know this yeah it's good doing
this thing nobody had a problem making
this show well we'll see
logistically yeah if it doesn't it's
only going to be because of numbers and
here's the thing though and i and i have
a problem with that i have a problem
with big streaming services
trying to tell us like hey we don't have
space in room you don't have space and
room on your hard drive
and let me finish too you know it's like
uh amazon you
make refrigerator money you got you you
literally have one of the rich he he
would be the richest man in the world if
he didn't get divorced
so you you got money to make these shows
that's just a choice i don't want to
hear about i want to join i want to tell
you more about what what the people i've
met though
go the people i've met
neuro diverse or connected to somebody
when they tell me what the show means to
them and thank me and thank you for the
show
and it's not it's not coming up to me
say hey dude love your show which is
important for entertainment aspects
that's great it's like after a show
after a comedy show you were funny i
don't need it
but sometimes they they mean it and they
wanted to express it it feels good and
they're giving you your flowers and good
for you and that is nice that we're
making good art they're not coming up to
me saying i was so entertained thanks
for entertaining me which that's part of
it that's part of it they're coming up
to me saying i finally saw my son i
finally saw myself
and
there was a girl that came up to me
after a screening for this
i mean
if she blinked their tears are going
down her face right right um
she has autism
and just wanting to take
i take a picture
and then we took the picture i'm sorry i
just it's just uh it's what you know the
show means a lot you know like one of
those things we're just like oh they're
gathering their things like this
performance
you know what i mean
it's like i'm i'm we're doing we're
gonna do it again
i'm i'm like in like we were just doing
uh speaking panel um which sidebar let
me say when we first started doing that
stuff i didn't want to i wasn't sure if
it was disrespectful to be silly and
every now and then i'll do a little joke
and i kept asking our show creator jason
is that okay and you'd be like yes and i
did enough to where i'm like now i'm
just it feels awesome it's like stand up
i just know i know i can just i'm
shining if i was in the audience i'd be
like well here's rick me and rick
it's beautiful yeah that's i'm not no no
shade on you there's also something to
the difference between stand up when
you're on stage alone and when you're up
with a group of people let alone it not
being a comedy so it's not a whole bunch
of jokes but just like
knowing that once you get your thing
you're not only is it okay for you to
stop you're supposed to so just being
able to just swing only when there's a
fastball it's really nice
and so many people don't know me that
i'm a comedian they just know me from
the show yeah so they're like you should
go to do a stand-up and i go oh that's
great i love it yeah yeah yeah but when
i'm but the point is you've been doing
that more anyway so that's been helping
i think
and talking about this real stuff on
stage yeah but these people that it
means so much to
like
if if they're not getting the numbers
they need if if they need this many
numbers and they get this many and this
show got this many and they were
entertained but all these people are
it's it's so important to them yeah i
had a girl come up to me recently also
shout out to family cafe i want to give
that was when i was in orlando this past
weekend it's this organization that uh
laurie i forgot i'm forgetting her last
name that she puts together it's 24th
year
i'm going to tell you what this
organization does that do you not care
go ahead uh you have a kid you go home
from the hospital there's no specific
rule book of how to take care of your
kid especially if they have a disability
so it's this thing for for this this
disability community that they've been
building for you don't necessarily know
every year they do this now i think i
think uh uh just thousands and thousands
of people come to this event every year
now it's free there's dental screenings
there's sensory rooms there's face
painting
all these things for the whole weekend
there's different people that come and
they speak and not only is it they're
offering help and assistance and tools
it's also literally this community of
all different types of people with
disabilities whether they have them a
child does a parent whatever comes
together and
it's just great um
what was the point i was making i was
there what were you just talking about
[ __ ] maybe i just wanted to shout out
these people yeah it's about what it
means to people at the show they're just
like the show oh i remember so there was
this there's this girl um i hate that
i'm forgetting their names but
um she's the youngest daughter of a
family of i think that she has uh
there's six of them the oldest uh her
brother has autism and everyone in the
family is close enough and everyone's
kind but
she says that she's the only one in the
family that truly connects to the
brother at least in the way that she
does
because there's some obstacles yeah the
she grew up with a brother brother six
seven years older she learned she
started playing video games because
that's when she hates she doesn't play
much she doesn't know how to play games
but that's how they could connect blah
blah she said that my character jack is
so much like her brother she learned so
much from her brother from watching the
show and like she grew up with the guy
but still being able to see it from
another perspective and that was just
like
anyway i'm talking too much about it now
i just i don't know it's good i mean
it's like i get it i didn't anticipate
the show i knew it would be important
because of the story we're telling i
didn't anticipate and being able to see
the faces of the people at this matters
too yeah and it's just it's just
powerful yeah because you're just like
doing a show because you want to be an
actor it's a great opportunity yeah i
get it you know you're you know you're
going to be on another show it's like it
is what it is and it's like uh but then
you just go oh wow this is like a whole
other level of like what art does
you know i mean i'm glad that they did
that you know i mean i have like i said
i have my own feelings about i'm not you
know inclusion and all this stuff is
great but i don't think everything has
to be so like like oh it has to be real
this has to be the realism like it's
like when they talk about euphoria and
they're like is this a realistic
depiction of high school like who the
hell wants to see that what we should
have zendaya in social studies class or
you could haves in diet you'd have to
have people that yeah yeah yeah yeah
ugly people they go to high school i was
just going to say they're ageless
they're ugly
there's so many memes where it's just
like a high school and they just look
like 13 and 15 year olds yeah and then a
netflix high school and they're 24 year
old models you know what i mean i just
think that i think that the the makers
of your four years should troll
everybody and film like them like
in a classroom and the teacher's up
there like you know teaching them and do
like 20 minutes of just that
oh you're saying yeah like a real
history yeah like a real like they do it
and then be like oh this is so
entertaining
this is so realistic they wouldn't see
that no man nobody wants to see that so
anyway what i'm saying is like there are
there is a feeling of people just being
like hey i want to be entertained
entertainment is supposed to be escapism
that's how i feel about it i want to
escape from reality if i want a reality
i go out to the post office you know
what i mean but at the same time when i
hear you talk about this and i hear that
people that it touches and moves and how
it affects me personally i also see
where i go hey this was important you
know it's like a comedy special supposed
to make you laugh and that is great some
also teach you stuff that's not
necessary not all specials
need to be rathaniel you know but shout
out to drude carmichael and rathaniel
fantastic special yeah well shout out to
rotheno um
uh i think he doesn't want people
knowing his name
but like that's a special thing but not
all special not all stand-up comedy
specials need to be that but that also
should exist yeah and that's great so if
you're making that show
then it makes sense to make it authentic
yeah if you're making a show that what
do you what do you want what are you are
you trying to get the most people to
watch this and you trying to get people
to like get the hottest people and the
people with the most followers because
that is a strategy and that's part of
what it is but when you're making a show
that's trying to be authentic
then you do want to be authentic with it
well you know well obviously
that was the thought process going in
yeah the creators obviously were like
let's get some autistic actors and
really show this let's tell a real story
and they did that they achieved it so
regardless if it gets picked up or or
not that piece of work is out there for
people and i highly recommend anybody uh
just to watch it just for the
entertainment value of it but also if
you have an autistic person in your
family or you're having trouble dealing
and you just want to see
you know a different way a different
perspective watch as we see it um
i want to read this uh so we're in emmy
magazine this month then there's like
it's right up and it's cool and blah
blah blah and there's
uh
the opening of it is just
i want you
it's what you make fun of me for all the
time
and i just don't want you to read it and
it helps you want me to read it out loud
yeah oh
while shooting the pilot the opening of
the of the article of the article while
shooting the pilot for as we see it
actor rick glassman thumbed ahead in the
script and saw that an upcoming scene
involved eating pizza he promptly
informed jason catherine's
catims the series showrunner writer
executive producer that he doesn't eat
cheese
cadams offered to have the prop pizza
made without cheese right like
so that's something that like
diva
right like no
no no no
diva
if this show was you know i'm saying
acting like a diva no no i'm saying it'd
be diva if it was like mandalorian three
and you're like a character in
mandalorian and you skimmed ahead and
during the thing you were like hey that
would be like fire that guy who the hell
does he think he is but the autism
autistic show starring the autistic
actors they were like okay but it also
oddly gave this environment of truly
being me yeah now sometimes you can't oh
sometimes you gotta just you gotta be
you know do a little different yeah but
not here and that was and then
then what does it say
rick was like no no no no cadem says
recalling how glassman insisted that the
piece of pizza be made normally playing
jack a character with autism glassman
who is also on the spectrum and
sensitive to taste and textures
and everything no it doesn't say that i
just added that
also though i am sensitive to it sounds
smells texture
i i just don't like cheese
that's not at all i mean he's a diva
wanted to peel the cheese off during the
scene exactly the way he does in real
life it added such a
specificity to the moment and to his
character ooh
so instead of it being like rick it's
tough they're like i love that no you
know you were showing that you're like
i'm an autistic artist
you know and maybe i'm an artist first
and then i'm autistic if they needed me
the cheese i would have said cast
somebody else i couldn't have done it
so i don't think art is first
i can't do cheese ladies and gentlemen i
hope you've enjoyed
let me read this one one more go ahead
he cites another whole freaking article
another telling trait glassman wanted to
slip into a scene the actor proposed
that jack sit down in an otherwise
hushed medical waiting room next to
someone noisily crunching on a bag of
chips i thought it'd be because i hate
the sounds of that but instead of just
saying great idea which they later do
they first do this so the entire
production stood by while someone ran
out and bought some chips to try it out
wow they're making you sound in the
final edit which incorporated the
munching jack's funny agonized
expression and vince's just how
disturbed that sound could be to someone
with auditory hypersensitivity so
oh works so difficult and then
but
in the final edit i feel that way about
the podcast like oh it's so exhausting
but in the edit it looks good
but it was cool reading that because it
was like it was just very honest rick is
this way rick is this way rick is this
way but it made for this this this i
don't know if i saw it like that i think
that it was like overall
showing the journey they wanted to take
in this production and they showed how
like you were completely like like you
were perfect for it
i tiptoed at first with certain things
and every time almost every time i did
they would
sometimes they would say no but but it
would always be understood and accepted
so then it got to the point where it
wasn't just i don't want to like anyway
it doesn't matter i just [ __ ] loved
the show and i loved working on it yeah
and you were great on it man and i and i
hope you know i hope something more
comes of it but you know regardless even
if it doesn't man it's out there you
know what i mean you i think that you
put yourself on the map as you know
because one it shows that like a a
person who is autistic can be can hold a
show
can be the star of a show uh it can be
worked with you know what i mean there
are all these all these conceptions that
people might have about someone who has
autism you know it's like yo you it
shows this article shows hey use these
things yeah there's an actor there's an
actor on the show
uh robbie and i'll put his instagram
handle if you want i'll send it to you
yeah he uh he has autism and played a
neurotypical character he played my boss
so like there's somebody with autism
who's playing somebody who doesn't have
autism
so it's like it goes i have a problem
with that yeah
it's like that
they're a good hard-working non-autistic
actors out here that can't get work and
you're telling me that your show
just teasing like how stupid oh
but just yeah but just piggybacking what
you're saying just like
they they're they could play these roles
but also it's not just these roles
just it's nice to give these people this
opportunity that otherwise may not have
before the show questions and get them
into the business question for you then
how difficult is that going to be
like like
you know it's not a show about autism
and then you know and it does say like
you got you know i've been on shows that
weren't about yeah but you gotta you
gotta eat the pizza you gotta like you
know well listen everything's different
you i think the biggest part of that is
learning how and that's what my
diagnosis helps so much for and what
it's so great being part of these
communities and learning from each other
is i am the way i am you are the way you
are we all are the way we are
being able to communicate to somebody
like i before any epic because we had
multiple directors before every episode
even though they knew what the subject
matter was i would talk to the directors
beforehand and tell them
the things about me
two minutes i just want to let you know
that i know some directors don't like
giving line reads because they think
actors don't like it
you you could give me any line read any
direction you have to be so direct to me
or i won't pick up on it so i just want
you to know if i'm doing something too
much or you want less of this or more of
something just straight up say rick you
need to do this
because then they'll talk to me a
certain way i undateable i found out
after the fact um and i don't know if
this is a blanketed statement or not but
like
apparently in in the multicam world the
directors won't and the writers don't
often give a line read or tell the actor
hey you're
trying to turn this joke this way
instead what they do is they just cut
the joke
oh so a lot of times a joke will make it
they'll like the joke it'll work in one
of the run-throughs
and you probably know this but i'll just
say this to them too
the way a multicam is filmed let's say
it usually takes a week so let's say you
get the script on a monday you rehearse
it all week you film it on friday so you
rehearse it and then on wednesday you do
a run through in front of the writers
yeah if something doesn't work they
either rewrite or cut it then you do it
in front of the network so there's all
like you almost have to like perform it
perfectly and you get one take and each
it's actually really crazy
and the more one to me the more
run-throughs you have in front of
whoever the worse it gets and that's
part of the craft of like like stand up
you have to repeat it a certain way yeah
but if if one time you don't turn the
joke right
a lot of times instead of saying hey
let's try it this way they just cut it
yeah it's weird
so if you tell them hey
you could tell me to do it a different
way
than they will
all right so that's that's what you're
what you're talking about right now is
like a coping mechanism what i'm saying
is communicate to people like hey
sometimes what i have to say is hey
sometimes
um especially because what the subject
matter of our show is i say hey
sometimes i get like really silly and
i'll be doing stuff and it'll be funny
and people are going to be laughing and
i'm going to be thinking we're having a
great time if i'm wasting time or you
know we're not going to use this you're
instead of
instead of me like can i try this and
like why don't you try one just be like
no
because a lot of times directors
especially because a tv director they're
like visiting yeah they're only there so
they want to be nice they'll be like
yeah go ahead just say rick don't do it
yeah and when you say that it just i
don't know it just makes it easier to
work that's interesting that you say
that because i think it is important to
like like i i actually enjoyed like when
i was doing i'm dying up here to to you
you know you talk to the director and
it's so it's different you know
everybody has a different uh-huh you
know they got a different thing i mean
i've never i've never done drama like
that so it was like it was interesting
interesting to see these like dramatic
actors like have these little like talks
before we even shoot a scene talks with
whom each other like they're talking
with the director and each actor and
they're looking and the writers there
they're kind of going like well in this
moment i'm you know and i was like wow
you know what i mean like it was like it
was very fascinating to witness
like you know what
a lot of the story is
is uh involving character intention yeah
where comedies are are though there is
intention it's the joke so we could talk
about the science of a joke what's this
punch line how do you set this up hey
could you lead me in with this as
opposed to
i'm feeling this way how do we
get our intentions out you know what i'm
gonna not that i'm not gonna disagree
with you but i'm gonna say that it's
more nuanced
in the sense of that i think that's what
makes comedy harder
because
there still is intention intention and
joke and the thing is
within this intention we also have to
it's they're almost like two different
things you know it's like it's like you
know it's like when you watch a show
like a movie like airplane you know a
spoof movie okay so there is a story
here here's you know it's a guy that was
is on a plane that is about to crash and
the pilot gets sick and this guy has to
fly the plane and like there's a real
story there like without all the
slapstick and at the same time while
we're telling this story we're going to
tell these jokes i mean i think that's
what makes comedy so much harder and
it's hard to that's why not everybody
can do it like it's comedy acting
i realize now when you're just worried
about intention and you just happen to
be funny in something it's different
from like here's the intention of this
scene and also we're trying to make a
really funny
but but because you don't have the jokes
and drama to to help bring things along
that means
that's why it's so important that you
are believable because like a lot of
times in comedies you would you you
could sack her and i don't always love
this but sometimes you'll sacrifice the
reality to get the joke and that's okay
because it's funny whatever it's funny
just do it you can't do that in the same
way in a drama so because it needs to be
so believable
you know grounded yeah
yeah man it's interesting you know it's
fast is it looking like as even as we're
talking about it like this i
uh i like talking about it like that i
mean but the thing is then you have to
forget all about it and then just do it
you know but there is something
fascinating about like and i wonder like
how was that on a show like as we see it
to not only have to have this intention
but also have to deal with your own
personal autism and then the autism of
the character i mean this is what people
say uh when they're they're accepting
awards but what actors say but it's true
um
for movies it's it's oftentimes given to
the director more but
if it's written well
you are you already know your intention
there's character stuff that you create
but
with jason each scene
has has an arc and a purpose
and you only have to have the simplest
script analysis to understand oh i'm
going from here to here we know that
right that's great and if you don't know
that you ask
but like
it's basically saying your job is to be
believable
as an actor but also
everything else is done for you
we're either literally guiding us just
just do it do your job get you the
rebounds
you
know
man that's
i mean you ever read some the
auditioning for something and there's
five pages for a scene yeah and it's
like
i gotta memorize this and sometimes it's
hard to memorize and sometimes you could
read it like three times
because it's written like oh i know why
so i don't have to memorize the words i
just know the story and and i would say
that that's a technique anyway for
memorizing that i use
like even like even something simple
like say going on a commercial audition
for you people out there i would tell
you is like my advice is get the joke
what is the joke
you know and then once you know the joke
the words don't really matter you have
to memorize the word you don't have to
memorize the words because you go this
is what i would say in this situation so
and in terms of like auditions i know
exactly what you mean you read something
you go and when it makes you go oh this
is great is because you go oh i love
that this person said this here and i
totally get why this person said that
and you get it but sometimes you read
something you go what what what why why
are they saying this and and and that
why are they saying this makes it harder
to memorize because it doesn't feel
intuitive it don't feel natural yeah man
jason
as you see i i could i mean i could read
it maybe twice but once and i have it
it's just he just writes it
well that's great man and i wish you all
the best with that i hope it does come
back but even if it doesn't you did a
great job you know
we're gonna no i was gonna say uh lastly
what we're gonna say is like i really
want to tell you like even on the
podcast in person like this is i'm
really looking forward to you being the
officiant of my wedding which is uh
gonna be well as of this it'll be next
week so yeah i think it's gonna be you
know it's it makes me feel i'm really
excited about it uh just the whole thing
getting married and all that and the
fact that you're gonna be a part of it
i'm excited and uh very i'll do this
i'll wash my hands before we eat okay uh
i'm nervous i'm a bit nervous so i'm i'm
i'm i'm ex you know you know what you're
gonna be fine i think so yeah i'm gonna
i got actually i'm gonna call jason and
have him ride out
make it intuitive
there's gonna be somebody eating chips
oh that's really funny also i would love
for him to do it i could at least pick
take some pieces it would be so dramatic
oh my god
we had to hire a violinist who's like
you know i'm bringing one
but anyway
we will show some of this on on yours or
my podcast yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
going to have i'm going to be snapping a
lot you're going to oh jesus please
don't do that it'll work in the edit
i'm rick glassman
scooter puppety blue
make sure you check out rick on his
podcast take your shoes off i was just
on the last episode or last week
whenever it was had such a great time
with your parents you i love your
parents that was such a fun time
um cleveland you know we did it in
cleveland and you know what
you know people keep saying it maybe
rick and i should start our own podcast
yeah we're talking about we're talking
about it you know we got so if you if
you want if this episode gets to 200 000
in the first month
we'll do it yeah let's spread the word
let's get it maybe maybe show us that we
should do it because you like seeing
this um and anything in the comments uh
uh
what's the guy's name american idol that
we liked
fritz yeah fritz lost
so i went from you know i talked to
fritz on instagram yeah you told me yeah
i'm just gonna get them on i said you
gotta come my podcast but i was gonna to
hit you up and be like we we
we should both like do it together yeah
and have him perform have oh man we
should just do a pot episode with us and
have him in the corner performing and
scoring it
he's not even on it he's just sitting
over there i have like a little webcam
or he's on my if we don't my place is on
the balcony but the curtains are closed
no but that kid is great and uh i wish
him the best uh he's he
like again just to not but like in that
kid christian too
like that the one episode he got kicked
off of that that song he sung i watched
that like five times oh the gospel one
that he sings in the car with his mom
all the time dude he was great uh it was
like just moving and the fact he didn't
make it i was like that's when i was
done i was out and i only stayed in it
because i wanted to see if fritz was
gonna win and then once he was out i was
like watch the finale no thank you i
skimmed through it i skimmed through i
watched it it was three hours yeah i
watched 20 minutes i skimmed through it
it's like lionel richie it's over bro
lionel richie has said for the last six
weeks
every time
you're finally an artist
and it's like you said it already no i
just think that i think that he's just
i'm not sure how old ronald richie is
but like he's like he's like he's lost
his voice really yeah he can't sing his
songs anymore not the way he used to
he's older i know i know but like i like
i do like him as a as a judge i love him
as a judge but but i wish they were a
little bit mean i wish one of them was a
little meaner
it's not meaner but just saying what
we're thinking yes we're missing the
science we're simon simon and katy perry
was doing it for a little while but i
think she was getting such pushback
because she's a pop star but she's now
an older like like aunt now so it's like
it's time for her to like be you katie i
love watching her like evolve she's like
this mom now you know what i mean she's
like but like like she's like not she's
not full-on kelly clarkson
i do like that she has when she's like
she she's thick now i'm like good go
good for you katie i like that she's uh
not making it about her as much as she
was in the earlier season yes yes yes
because she is great she's great pick
your pockets did you see the last did
you see like last season or whatever
that one like soft-spoken
blonde white guy that plays guitar uh he
he he sang a song with her one of her
songs i don't remember oh man i gotta
send it to you i'll post put it right
here oh wow
but like dude
she's still she's still got it she's a
great singer you know so but i like the
advice she gives and other kind of stuff
so anyway check out american
idol um
again check out taking shoes off uh i'll
have footage of the wedding and stuff
like that uh when it when you know a
couple weeks and i'll be uh you know a
married guy even though i already feel
like it now my my beautiful
fiancee and future wife rachel uh rick
and her have a great relationship and
it's like you know it's gonna be great
i'm looking forward to it and thanks for
watching uh uh riffin with griffin i
haven't had a guest in a while forget
the name of your show a little bit yeah
because i never i don't do this anymore
right because it's like i don't normally
have a guest but let's do it we got food
downstairs and i'm hungry yeah we're
gonna do it peace out thanks a lot you
put in your theme music your mind
just send me your stupid music it's
playing right now use yours
it's just jesus takes the wheel
i wish we could
[Music]
are we still filming this
put that
show whose fault that was
you right away go to me
eric eric i want you to watch that